all right
all right welcome back it is time for in
a minute and today we are teaming up
with the makers of lumify eye
illuminations and their spokesperson
celebrity makeup artist Vincent okendo
and today he's going to share tips on
maintaining beautiful and healthy
looking eyes so I wanted to share with
you some of these gorgeous amazing
products um is launching new lumify eye
illuminations which was created for the
areas surrounding the eyes there's a
hydrogel brightening cream a nourishing
lash and brow serum and a three-in-one
micellar cleansing water and eye makeup
remover each of these formulas is
hypoallergenic and non-irritating and by
the way here in this chair it's someone
I know very well her name is Catherine
Hertz and she is a producer here at our
show and
you're already a fan of lumify Catherine
oh yeah I use their eye drops okay so
Vincent shall we try the new three in
one cleansing water and eye makeup
remover actually I got to play with some
Flower Beauty on her today
she's wearing the spotlight highlighter
and we've got some of the pigment on her
lid and then we got that yummy lip balm
on so you want to shake this up
and what I'm doing is I'm using a
reusable makeup pad so what I'm going to
do is I just roll it on the eyes to
break it down and this is a three in one
makeup remover yes I like how you're
rolling it yeah God I look like I'm
raking leaves when I do it well because
the skin around the eyes is some of the
most delicate skin on your face on your
whole body actually oh my God and it all
came off yeah see these are the moments
that are going to change my life forever
oh my God Vincent I'm gonna do my makeup
removal differently yeah okay everybody
our audience is gonna go home with a
bundle of lumify eye illuminations
nourishing lash and brow serum plus the
redness reliever eye drops by Bausch and
loam
company I too want whiter brighter
healthier eyes I want to remove my
makeup differently I can't wait to use
this product and I can't wait to apply
it the way you did Vincent thank you
well thank
you thanks because we make this show for
you so just take it with you
foreign
[Music]